Carol Peletier's journey is one of the most
wide-ranging in The Walking Dead: She begins
as a battered wife but ends up a queen, a
warrior, and above all, a survivor.
With a spinoff focused on her and Daryl Dixon
on the horizon, there's never been a better
time to explore her entire story.
Carol has been a survivor for many years.
Prior to the story's start, she meets and
marries Ed Peletier, who quickly becomes abusive
toward both Carol and their daughter Sophia.
When the apocalypse hits, the family tries
to go to Atlanta, only to realize that the
government is in more of a Napalming mood
than a helping one.
While stuck in traffic, the Peletiers befriend
Lori, Shane and Carl, who manage to get them
and a handful of other survivors to a campsite
just outside the city while they figure out
their next move.
There, Ed's abusive behavior continues, but
now it's happening under the watchful eye
of a former police officer and a group of
like-minded women.
Shane eventually beats an appropriate amount
of snot out of Ed for slapping Carol in front
of everyone.
As a result of his injuries, Ed isn't exactly
in fighting shape when walkers descend on
the camp.
He's killed and eventually put down before
becoming a walker by none other than Carol
herself, marking her first step towards independence.
"I'll do it.
He's my husband."
After the survivors go to the CDC and discover
how dire their situation truly is, they set
out on the road once again.
Unfortunately, they are waylaid when their
RV gives up the ghost.
When a herd of walkers approaches, Carol is
separated from Sophia.
Rick tries his best to save her, but he too
is separated from the child in the thick Georgia
woods.
It isn't long before the group discovers Sophia
is a walker, locked up with her undead brethren
in a barn, and Rick is forced to put her down.
When the farm they've taken refuge at is overrun
by walkers, Carol isn't much help in the ensuing
battle.
With no one to guide her and no real fighting
skills to speak of, she must rely on others
to stay alive.
After a brief, failed attempt to replace her
former husband with Daryl, Carol begins to
understand that her survival is in her hands
and no one else's.
Season three begins with a minor time jump
that reveals a very new Carol.
She's gained a lot more confidence in the
intervening months and a whole lot of new
skills, ranging from combat to medicine.
The loss of her family has hardened her in
a unique way: She is no longer afraid of Ed's
wrath, nor of losing Sophia.
When the survivors hole up in a prison, she
busies herself with first aid and preparations
to deliver Lori's baby.
Unfortunately, a walker attack sets those
plans aside and Carol is trapped alone in
an overrun part of the prison for several
days.
Fortunately, Daryl finds her and nurses her
back to health, as she once did for him when
he was injured looking for Sophia.
Their relationship is stronger than it's ever
been when Daryl's older brother, Merle, returns
to the picture.
Carol sees a lot of Ed in Merle and tries
to encourage Daryl not to lose the man he's
become, in favor of reverting back to who
he was around his older brother.
In their final interaction together before
he dies, Merle comments on how different Carol
has become since the last time he saw her
at the camp outside Georgia.
"Well you don't seem scared of nothing anymore."
"I'm not."
When the war with the Governor and Woodbury
begins, Carol proves just how right he is
by encouraging Andrea to assassinate the Governor.
After the citizens of Woodbury are welcomed
into the prison, Carol begins teaching the
children how to kill walkers.
Soon, a flu starts spreading throughout the
prison, and Carol takes it upon herself to
execute two carriers in an effort to stop
the spread.
When Rick figures out what she's done, he
banishes her from the group.
As a result, she's away when the Governor
returns to destroy the prison.
In the aftermath of the attack, Carol finds
Tyreese, who has rescued young sisters Lizzie
and Mika, as well as Lori's baby, Judith.
Together, they find their way to a small cottage
where they decide to figure out their next
move.
While there, Lizzie starts to develop a soft
spot for walkers.
Carol and Tyreese try to get her to change
her mind after a few encounters with dangerous
walkers, but it's all for naught: Lizzie eventually
kills Mika, convinced that she'll be back
as a walker and that everything will be fine.
What's more, Lizzie confesses that she's planning
to do the same to the baby.
Realizing how far gone she is and how much
of a threat she poses to the rest of them,
Carol and Tyreese silently agree to execute
her, which Carol, now a grizzled survivor,
is willing to do.
They agree to never speak of it again.
"Just… just look at the flowers."
Eventually, the group arrives at Terminus,
and Carol and Tyreese realize that it's crawling
with cannibals who have taken their friends
hostage.
Carol launches a one-woman, full-frontal assault
on the compound, almost single-handedly taking
it down with some clever explosions and a
herd of walkers.
Thanks to her bravery, she's welcomed back
to the group, but it isn't exactly the boon
to survival it once was.
With the prison gone and Terminus a proven
sham, the remaining survivors wander the woods
aimlessly.
After Beth is kidnapped by a group of vicious
survivors living at a hospital, Carol ends
up getting hit by a car and taken into the
belly of the beast, where she spends a good
deal of time unconscious before Daryl and
company rescue her.
Their fates change when Aaron arrives and
invites them to be a part of the Alexandria
safe haven.
But Carol is skeptical of this apparently
apocalypse-proof community -- she reverts
back to her cheery old housewife persona,
lying in wait for the moment her true new
nature will be needed.
It doesn't take long before she and Rick discover
a man in the community, Pete, is abusing his
wife and kid.
Carol stops baking cookies for a moment to
threaten Pete's life, ultimately turning that
particular conflict over to Rick, who executes
him.
With Rick pretty much in charge of Alexandria,
Carol is forced to abandon her housewife act
when a group of nomadic survivors known as
the Wolves infiltrate the camp and start killing
its citizens.
She dons a disguise and manages to almost
single-handedly stop the invasion, blowing
her cover within the community forever.
Fortunately, her bloodthirsty nature is curtailed
a bit by the arrival of Morgan, who's on a
warrior monk kick and doesn't want to kill
living people.
That attitude, coupled with a new love interest
by the name of Tobin, helps Carol pull back
from the abyss of violence.
Unfortunately, this comes just as the group
fires their first shots in what becomes an
all-out-war with their toughest enemy yet,
the Saviors.
When Rick agrees to take on an outpost held
by their new enemy, Carol finds herself kidnapped
alongside a pregnant Maggie, and she's forced
to use every bit of her cleverness to escape.
However, the experience sours her to warfare,
prompting her to leave Alexandria and Tobin.
Unfortunately, she's too late, as the Saviors
are already monitoring who goes in and out
of the colony.
She's gravely wounded in a one-versus-five
skirmish.
Just when it looks like she's about to be
executed, Morgan arrives to save her.
"Will you please just let me go?"
"It's not your time."
Carol wakes up in the Kingdom, an enigmatic
colony where everyone defers to the judgement
of King Ezekiel.
After some lighthearted bonding with Ezekiel,
she decides she still wants to be alone, but
settles on an abandoned cottage that's not
too far from the Kingdom.
She crosses paths with the Alexandrians again
when Rick and the gang seek the Kingdom's
help in overthrowing the Saviors.
Carol has an emotional reunion with Daryl,
during which he lies and tells her that the
Saviors haven't hurt any of their people.
Morgan reveals this to be a lie, however,
and Carol opts to get back to what she does
best: protect the people she cares about.
"We have to get ready.
We have to fight."
By the time she convinces Ezekiel to bring
the Kingdom's forces to Alexandria's aid,
Negan has managed to breach the walls of the
safe haven and subdue Rick and his fighters.
The brash villain is about to execute Carl
as punishment for what he sees as Rick's rebellion
when he's stopped by the united forces of
the Kingdom and the Hilltop.
And just like that, Carol finds herself as
a general in the Kingdom's army against the
Saviors.
It doesn't take long for Carol to become one
of the most important fighters in the rebel
army.
She leads right beside King Ezekiel as members
of his faction ambush a Savior outpost in
the hope of obtaining heavy weapons.
Just when the mission seems to have succeeded,
however, the group is cut down by a hail of
gunfire.
Only Ezekiel, Carol and Jerry are left standing.
Heroically, Carol makes one more bid to obtain
the weapons, but ultimately decides to save
her allies instead.
These events leave Ezekiel in a spiral of
self-pity.
Carol employs tough love to help him out of
it, and the two eventually become makeshift
parents to a youngster named Henry.
When Negan launches a counter-attack on the
Kingdom, Carol is able to get everyone out
in time.
They retreat to the Hilltop, where they quickly
learn that Negan has also taken out Alexandria.
With just one safe haven left, the entire
army prepares for a last stand.
A battle ensues, in which Carol is forced
to put Tobin down.
In the fray, Henry runs off, forcing Carol
and Morgan to go looking for him, killing
walkers and Saviors along the way.
They rejoin Rick's army just in time to witness
all the Saviors' guns backfire, allowing them
to finally defeat Negan.
A year and a half later, Carol reigns as queen
of the Kingdom, having started a romantic
relationship with Ezekiel.
Meanwhile, their colony, the Hilltop, and
Alexandria are doing their best to rebuild
and assimilate the Saviors and their Sanctuary
into their ranks.
Unfortunately, things aren't going well, as
constant in-fighting and small acts of defiance
threaten the very terse alliance.
Carol personally takes over control of the
Sanctuary briefly, but it doesn't last, as
several of the more defiant members leave
just before Rick sacrifices himself to unite
the groups.
Six years go by, and she and Ezekiel continue
to keep the Kingdom running while raising
young Henry.
In an effort to make him more useful, she
escorts him on a trip to the Hilltop so he
can learn blacksmithing and finishes off a
group of former Saviors along the way.
"I swear you'll never see us again."
"I know."
Back at the Kingdom, Ezekiel is busying himself
with a fair that he hopes will convince the
three allied colonies to sign a charter that
will bind them to each other for life.
This finally comes to fruition when the Alexandrians
ask the Kingdom to harbor Lydia, the daughter
of the Whisperers' leader, Alpha.
Furious at the kidnapping, Alpha builds a
border that she makes clear the group is never
to cross.
Marking the border is a line of heads on spikes
... including Henry's.
Carol is devastated by Henry's death.
She leaves Ezekiel shortly after getting the
remaining survivors to the Hilltop, after
the Kingdom succumbs to deterioration.
She sets off to live life by herself as a
fisherwoman, but eventually returns, still
holding a grudge against Alpha.
When a satellite crash-lands near the Oceanside
colony, they all have to cross the border
to put out the fire.
This causes Alpha to unleash a relentless
herd upon them.
When they meet for peace talks, Carol pulls
a gun on Alpha.
Fortunately, Alpha is in a forgiving mood.
It is revealed that Carol has been taking
pills to keep awake, both as a survival strategy
and to avoid dreams of what her life could
have been.
After the group discovers this, she's taken
back to Alexandria for treatment.
She promptly leaves to take revenge on Alpha's
herd.
However, in a shocking twist, it's revealed
that killing the herd is just one part of
Carol's revenge plan: She also frees Negan
from captivity in Alexandria, with the sole
purpose of having him assassinate Alpha.
"So you bring me Alpha's head, and that's
what the people will remember you for."
He succeeds, but Carol isn't able to finish
off the herd.
She returns to the survivors and attempts
to sacrifice herself in order to walk the
zombies off a cliff, but she's saved by Lydia
at the last moment, effectively ending the
Whisperers' reign of terror.
Carol returns to the camp where she has an
important conversation to fully reconcile
with Daryl, who she's spent the better part
of a year at odds with despite otherwise being
each other's greatest ally.
Daryl asks if she got what she wanted during
the battle.
She admits, without actually saying it, that
she now realizes she never actually wanted
to die, even in a heroic sacrifice.
With the Whisperers a thing of the past, Carol
is ready to take on all comers with her best
friend at her side and a new zest for life.
Daryl then asks if she may want to hit the
road for New Mexico, to which she notes that
there are still things they need to do at
home first.
This is the clearest setup for her spinoff
in The Walking Dead franchise beyond the flagship
series ending after season 11.
Norman Reedus told Entertainment Weekly that
he and Melissa McBride's series will be more
of a road show than anything else, meaning
the duo will fight one more battle before
going off into the sunset together.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.